die Angst von der Energiekrise in diesem
Winter es geht dabei nicht nur ums Geld
was passiert wenn beispielsweise in der
Hauptstadt die Lichter ausgehen in
Berlin wenn Tankstellen und Supermärkte
schließen und Heizungen ausfallen weil
der Strom abgeschaltet ist kommt es dann
zu Unruhen zu plünder rein was nach
Panik mache klingt ist ein ganz
konkretes Szenario auf dass die Berliner
Polizei sich hinter den Kulissen
vorbereitet
[Musik]
seit Monaten schreiben Experten des LKA
und der Landespolizeidirektion an einem
Geheimpapier der Titel Energiekrise
die Polizei Berlin fokussiert sich
hierbei auf die Wahrscheinlichkeit des
Eintretens bestimmter Reaktionen Ziel
ist in einem möglichen Ernstfall schnell
und wirkungsvoll zum Schutz der
Bevölkerung handeln zu können wie BILD
erfuhr ist das Konzept im Zusammenhang
mit möglichen Einschränkungen der
Energieversorgung in drei
Eskalationsstufen eingeteilt
Phase 1 Verteuerung
das Szenario wird bereits als gegeben
angesehen heißt es im Entwurf wird unter
anderem davon ausgegangen dass es zu
Demonstrationen und Kundgebungen kommt
in denen der Unmut darüber ausgedrückt
wird
Phase 2 Verknappung
nach Einschätzung der Experten könnte es
in den kommenden Monaten tatsächlich
dazu kommen Energien wie Strom und Gas
werden rationiert nur zu bestimmten
Zeiten werde es möglich sein zu heizen
zu kochen warm zu duschen auch ein
Problem für die Feuerwehr Menschen
fangen an vermehrt mit Feuer zu heizen
das erhöhe die Brandgefahr erheblich die
Polizei hingegen muss eine rund um die
Uhr Bereitschaft gewährleisten
Notstromaggregate satelliten-handys und
gefüllte mobile Tanks für die
kraftfahrzeuge sind vorzuhalten die
Abfragen an alle Liegenschaften dazu
laufen gerade auf Hochtouren
[Musik]
Phase 3 Ausfall
im Papier geht die Polizei von einem
partiellen Ausfall der Energieversorgung
aus doch wenn der sogenannte Blackout da
ist sei mit Plünderungen Unruhen und
Angriffen auf die kritische
Infrastruktur zu rechnen
Bargeldautomaten fallen aus Züge und
Bahnen bleiben auf offener Strecke
stehen
Mobilfunknetze Versagen orientiert an
den drei Szenarien werden die
Kriminalitätslage das
versammlungsgeschehen sowie das
allgemeine Verhalten der Bevölkerung
betrachtet und daraus polizeiliche
Handlungsnotwendigkeiten abgeleitet
[Musik]
das antikaos-papier wird zurzeit noch
Behörden intern abgestimmt nach
Bildinformationen soll es spätestens
Ende des Monats fertiggestellt und der
Behördenleitung vorgelegt werden
[Musik]
da horcht man schon auf sprechen wir
noch darüber und zwar mit der Professor
bavin Bandelow
erforscht Angst Erkrankungen an der
Universität Göttingen und mit Robert
jungnischke er ist ein Blackout Experte
Ingenieur und Sachverständiger
vielleicht Herr junges Spiel zuerst die
Frage an Sie wie wahrscheinlich ist es
dass es tatsächlich zu so einem Blackout
kommen kann und wie lange wird er dann
anhalten was wird dann passieren okay
ähm ganz wichtig man muss zunächst mal
klarstellen der Blackout ist kein
Stromausfall sondern hat ganz andere
auslösende Ursachen nämlich die großen
Kraftwerke trennen sich vom Stromnetz
und dadurch wird eben das Stromnetz
komplett vom Strom befreit wenn man so
möchte und damit funktioniert rein gar
nichts mehr und bei einem Stromausfall
ist das immer ein lokales Ereignis was
bedeutet dass dann eben nur ein
Teilbereich betroffen ist und das ist
eben dieser große Unterschied bei einem
Blackout müssen wir damit rechnen dass
es mindestens mal Deutschland betrifft
vielleicht sogar ganz Europa und die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist meiner Meinung
nach bei 99,9 Prozent
99,9% zu einem Blackout in Europa kommt
in diesem Winter ja also wir haben wenn
der Verbrauch so ist wie er die letzten
Jahre immer ist was Gas angeht dann
werden wir Ende Januar kein Gas mehr
haben das heißt dann muss zumindest mal
rationiert werden und wir können ja kein
Gas rationieren weil man kann ja nicht
zu jedem Haushalt gehen und den gasthahn
zudrehen das heißt man wird das über den
Strom machen und die Frage ist halt bei
der jetzigen Situation des Stromnetzes
also wir haben stand gestern ungefähr
9.603 ich habe die Zeit jetzt nicht
genau im Kopf Redis patchmaßnahmen bis
zum gestrigen Tage gehabt wir hatten im
ganzen genau ich komme jetzt dazu wir
hatten
das sind die Eingriffe die die
Netzbetreiber machen müssen um unser
Stromnetz stabil zu halten also 9.600
und ein paar gequetschte Eingriffe waren
erforderlich damit unser Stromnetz nicht
um die Ohren fliegt gut also hoffen wir
mal dass es unsere nicht um die Ohren
fliegt
99,9%, das klingt nach einer steilen
these auch Herr Bandelow wann was
passiert in so einem Moment mit uns mit
der Psyche der Menschen sollte es
tatsächlich zu so einem Blackout kommen
welche
Übersprungshandlungen können dann auch
passieren ja ich glaube nicht dass es
wirklich solche Szenarien geben wird
dass das ist so Plünderung gibt man hat
sowas ja beobachtet zum Beispiel in New
York 1977 gab es tatsächlich bei einem
Blackout dann
3.700 Leute die verhaftet worden sind
wegen Plünderungen im nächsten
Stromausfall 2003 waren das gab es nur
noch vier Einbrüche weil die Polizei
auch vorbereitet war ich glaube
eigentlich nicht dass das so kommen wird
aber wir müssen uns natürlich auf
einiges gefasst machen trotzdem hatten
wir ja auch schon in der corona-krise
gesehen dass Menschen auch wirklich echt
extrem gut und diszipliniert
zusammenarbeiten können wir wenn wir
wirklich in Krisen kommen und auch
überschätzt man komplett also die
Widerstandsfähigkeit die Resilienz der
Bevölkerung wenn man jetzt schon diese
Aufstände und Plünderungen herbeired ich
denke
wir haben sehr viele Ressourcen und
werden auch sehr schwierige Situationen
durchstehen können ja jetzt reden wir es
nicht herbei sondern die Berliner
Polizei geht dieses Szenarien ja durch
schon mal und wir sehen ja auch Herr
Bandel das ist ja in der Tat auch Wut
gibt die aus Angst heraus dass
Existenzangst heraus die Menschen
durchaus auch auf die Straße treibt die
ersten Montagsdemonstrationen
sogenannten gehen schon wieder los
ja ist natürlich solche Demonstrationen
nutzen uns ja wenig weil
der Staat kann ja den Strom nicht
herzaubern und das da hilft das ganze
demonstrieren nicht ich denke das ist so
ähnlich wie sein wird wie in
corona-zeiten das dann erstmal eine
Gruppe schon tatsächlich auch große
Demonstrationen macht die dann
eigentlich aber immer auch weniger
werden weil die Menschen einsehen dass
wir eigentlich jetzt alle mal
zusammenhalten müssen und das ist
wahrscheinlich auch Einschränkungen
geben wird aber das ist dann nichts
nicht unbedingt sinnvoll ist einfach zu
protestieren sondern einfach
lieber zu überlegen was man gemeinsam
tun kann dass alle zusammenhalten dass
zum Beispiel auch nicht unvernünftige
Dinge geschehen zu corona-zeiten war es
ja dass gehortet wurde
Brot oder Mehl und und Toilettenpapier
das wird wahrscheinlich auch wieder ein
bisschen kommen da muss jeder auch so
ein bisschen Zivilcourage zeigen und
eben zusammenhalten dass da nicht wieder
das Chaos durch Panik einige
Verhaltensweisen entsteht wenn zum
Beispiel dann die Leute alle 600.000
Heizlüfter die in letzter Zeit gekauft
worden sind gleichzeitig laufen lassen
dann ist auch die Katastrophe da Herr
wandelow ganz herzlichen Dank dafür Herr
junges letzte Frage ganz kurz zum
Abschluss noch sollte es tatsächlich zu
so einem Blackout kommen wie lange
dauert das bis man das im Griff hat dann
wieder also
bis der Strom wieder da ist wird maximal
oder wird wahrscheinlich so um ein bis
zwei Wochen dauern aber damit hat man
gar nichts im Griff fällt danach geht es
erst richtig los weil bis die Systeme
wieder funktionieren bis alle
Datendienste wieder funktionieren bis
alle ich sag mal Logistik und alles
wieder funktioniert Jahre wird es dauern
weil man darf nicht vergessen beim
Blackout wäre zum Beispiel werden
sämtliche ja tiererzeugungsbetriebe
werden ihre Tiere verlieren sämtliche
gewächshauskulturen werden kaputt gehen
weil das ist alles hochautomatisiert das
braucht alles Strom und der ist ja nicht
mehr da das ist das schlimme ist wir
reden hier über einen Zustand den gab es
noch nie und das ist halt das Problem es
wird immer über Stromausfall gesprochen
aber ein Blackout ist kein Stromausfall
sondern viel dramatischer
[Musik]